I'm Ted Conover and I'm here today
speaking with Piper Kerman about orange
is the new black hi Piper
I wondered as I read your book about the
ways in which Danbury sticks with you
and one of the great revelations of your
book to me was what happens on Mother's
Day could you recall a little bit of
that what it what it's like and why it
means anything there at all I think that
Mother's Day was one of the most intense
days that I experienced in Danbury and I
am not a mother of course I've got a mom
who came to visit me that day and that's
a that was one of our most wonderful
visits my mother was an incredible
source of strength during the entire
legal proceedings and certainly during
the time that I was incarcerated and one
of the things that I really remember
striking me when I was thinking back on
my mom and Mother's Day and of course of
writing the book was that I can't
remember ever seeing my mother beaten by
anything and that really came through I
can only imagine that my legal travails
were one of the most challenging things
she ever experienced but she was just an
incredible source of strength for me
Mother's Day started though long before
I saw my own mom in the visiting room
the moment that we woke up that day and
you wake up pretty early in prison as
I'm sure you know everyone began to wish
each other a happy Mother's Day because
almost all women in prison are mothers I
think the statistic is around 80% and it
was so important because I think that on
that day of all days mothers missed
their children they miss their children
every single day but that's a tough day
because you really confront whatever
mistakes you've made as an individual
that have put you behind bars on such an
important day when you're supposed to be
able to celebrate your relationship with
your children many children their
families make tremendous efforts to get
them up to the prison
Mother's Day that's really not possible
though for so many families most
families most people in prison are
indigent they're poor people and even
Danbury which is not that far from New
York City where so many women who are
incarcerated there are from it's an
incredibly challenging journey we're
talking subways trains taxis and
sometimes if you've got a bunch of kids
who are coming to visit their mom that's
a really daunting proposition yeah sure
it's it's a huge barrier for family
reunification which is it important for
again those that huge percentage of
women prisoners who when they do come
home and almost all of us are coming
home you know want to be reunified with
their children and their children want
to be reunified with them right
I guess that question sort of started us
in the middle I know that before you
arrived there you had other things on
your mind I I read your piece in the
life's column of the times of it was
this impending collision of two worlds
the comfortable middle-class
college-educated world you came from in
the tough world that that prison is
especially in the popular mind I think a
dangerous place for people from your
background and one of the things a
reader is waiting to find out when you
enter prison is how bad is this going to
be level so for me reading the book was
starting with that expectation and then
seeing that's not exactly the way it
plays out for you I don't think you got
punched am i right I didn't get punched
nope I didn't gets locked either that's
them sort of the worst prison weapon I
ever heard about in the course of the
time that I was incarcerated which is a
lock and a sock which is you know a
daunting weapon but not one that ison
use more at legend mm-hmm for me that's
a huge fear the fear of violence is a
fear that certainly my family and my
friends had for me and I certainly was
afraid of violence mice
self though the very limited amount of
information I'd been able to gather
about women in prison as opposed to you
know men in prison indicated to me that
maybe that might not be what I was
facing but still I think that day that I
self surrendered you know in Danbury the
main thing was just the massive
uncertainty for a complete unknown and I
think for middle-class people who are
not subject to the pre criminal justice
system as often as as poor people it is
a huge unknown and so I had no idea what
to expect and the thing that was so
shocking
once I was finally processed in which
was a very scary experience and once I
was actually in the general population
as they say
among the other women and a cacophonous
you know so many people that's one of
the things prisons are so crowded that
that's one of the things that you
immediately have to sort of adjust to is
just the crush of humanity yeah of all
you know shapes sizes colors voices
accents languages swirling around me
women began to approach me and I was
scared and they said things like are you
okay do you need some toothpaste right
it's gonna be alright this is a really
bad day but it'll get better I was
waiting to see if some of them were
playing you were what trying to win you
over early before you knew the score
sure and I think that that's a factor
but I always when folks ask me about
that the idea that someone might cozy up
to you in the in the hopes of gaining
some advantage either over you or you
know getting something from you my
feeling is that that was always really
obvious right and transparent and so and
there was no true physical risk for sure
of sort of brushing that off or you know
politely or gently sort of giving the
cold shoulder to that and to be careful
I mean you had to be really soft
I would say the one of the ironic things
that I found about prison was elaborate
necessity to be respectful uh-huh and
this very I mean there's most people in
prison have not gotten a lot of respect
throughout their entire lives and have
also potentially not been respectful to
other people but that idea of respect is
so central you know you you know they
take everything away from you right down
to your underpants and all you have left
sometimes is this concept of respect and
beaks so that becomes incredibly
important and whether you're respectful
to other people whether other people are
respectful to you becomes this
incredible currency right I think um
that's something I learned early on too
when I was a correction officer that
image of a Steve McQueen wearing dark
glasses and Cool Hand Luke and saying
you know you there you there you there
maybe if you're big and strong with a
lot of fellow officers around you can
afford to address inmates
that way but my experience was that
treating people respectfully or
addressing them respectfully and not you
know you not calling people by
vulgarities works a lot better people
respond better and I'm sure that is true
between inmates as well it's certainly
true between inmates with some
exceptions there are some people who are
for for a variety of reasons having a
lot of trouble conferring respect to
others right but when it comes to
officers that's a really interesting
point I think there are certainly
officers who simply by their physical
imposing force command fear if not
respect but the officers are I think at
least in danbury and in the other
facilities that I lived in were most
respected we're definitely the ones who
were most likely to acknowledge our
humanity and also to enforced rules I
mean I think in truth an officer who
didn't enforce rules people might have
liked that officer but they didn't
necessarily respect them in the same way
than someone who was incredibly
consistent right unfair
humane yep so just to finish up on that
theme being a college educated person
did it bring any drawbacks at all to you
in there I really don't think it did
well I know that some folks sort of have
this idea that perhaps I might have been
targeted or a person who's had many
privileges or opportunities in life
would be targeted and I can only speak
from my own experience but no I was far
from the only middle-class white woman
in that facility right I was not I was
not alone in that sort of demographic
yeah but you know there were a vast
majority of people who didn't
necessarily come from the same
background but I what I found in prison
is that what we have in common is much
more important than those divisions I
mean I think that the disparity of
opportunity is stark when you're a
prisoner and when you are part of that
world and you see who gets put in prison
and who doesn't the different what the
impact of equality of opportunity or the
lack thereof comes to full fruition in
the present system yes so I'm certainly
not saying it's not an important thing
right but in the interpersonal
interrelations that I had with folks you
know behind prison walls what we had in
common was much more important yeah so I
know that Jean Harris another famously
incarcerated person from an educated
background left her incarceration with a
real agenda to help people in there I
read some of the same from Martha
Stewart when she got out it turns out
that that's really what your book is
about is an immersion and a witnessing
of this incredibly unjust system
obviously it's about your own story as
well but I was I guess maybe it's it's
just the way all of our books have to
have
a cover orange is the new black my year
in a woman's prison made me think oh
it's going to be all about Piper Kerman
and and what she's going through but as
it turns out that that's that's not it
and as it when you were in prison were
you thinking about the book you might
write and what it might be about I
didn't plan to write a book while I was
incarcerated though my bunkie you know
the woman who I lived with for many
months she was finishing up an
eight-year sentence
I used to turn to me sometimes at
moments of true chaos in B dorm and say
bunkie you go home and write a book so I
took her I took her seriously but while
I was in prison I was a little more
focused frankly on just prevailing
day-by-day
yeah but when I came home there was a
high degree of interest from many many
quarters meaning that everyone wanted to
sit down and hear about the relation the
experience in great detail in surprising
surprisingly voracious appetite for
details and some folks would be willing
to sit and listen just for hours you'd
be like okay tell the whole story yeah
but the story is not just my story the
story is about the intersection of my
life with other people's lives and the
recognition of the impact of my own
actions on others I think that an
indifference to the suffering of others
is at the heart of all crime it's
certainly at the heart of my own crime
and unfortunately it's really at the
heart of the way the system operates as
well so I think it just reinforces
unfortunately the very factor that lands
so many people in prison you mentioned
the idea of restorative justice part way
through I've three times proposed
articles on the restorative justice
movement to various magazines and
somehow they're not as interested in it
for those who don't know this is of
course the idea that true justice
consists of criminals making some kind
of amends or you know attending to the
results of their crime with the people
who suffered from it directly
confronting the
their actions yes and we're not set up
that way at all at all not at all
there's no factor of the sentence of any
one sentence that really includes
bringing a person to true account right
we think of of confinement as bringing
someone to account but I think that the
way that the system works an individual
who has committed a crime and is being
called to account is so preoccupied with
their own role as a protagonist in that
struggle and surviving the system and
surviving this not just the correctional
system but the criminal justice system
as a whole that it's very easy for those
individuals to get very far away from
whatever harm they may have caused and
that's really a system problem far more
than a simple issue of personal
responsibility right though there's a
quite a fascinating moment in orange is
the new black well you reflect
frequently on how many people around you
are incarcerated for long periods of
time for nonviolent drug crimes and in
fact that whole phrase nonviolent drug
crime suggests over harsh punishment I
think and yet there's a moment where you
see some of the conditions of the people
around you and you think about your own
crime and I wonder if you could talk
about that absolutely I mean there were
a lot of instances there were so many
people I met in prison who were in
prison for drug offenses but also so
many people who had been addicted to
drugs often their offense was connected
to they're directly connected to their
addiction also so many women whose
health had been devastated by their use
of drugs either in the form of you know
sort of the ravages of addiction but
also in terms of hepatitis C or HIV and
in the books specifically I talked about
my friendship with a woman who I worked
with in the construction of shop she was
not serving time for a drug crime
actually but she was a drug addict and
she was completely clean in prison but
she couldn't wait and she was very
straightforward
about her anticipation of hitting the
streets and getting back to using drugs
a very bright woman you know a very
intelligent woman and she was completely
straightforward and I would I would
argue with her about that I would say
you're clean now you know the deal she
would say you just don't understand
Piper and McChrystal izing moment for me
in terms of her intent on oblivion and
my role in that and that's a devastating
thing because I cared about this woman a
lot and I feared for her future what was
your role in her oblivion
you know I contributed to the drug trade
and I tell I carried a bag of money I
became involved in with a with a woman
romantically who was a narcotics
trafficker bringing her around the globe
and she asked me at one point to carry a
bag of money from Chicago to Brussels
and I agreed to do it a big bag of drug
money to go where I don't know but I
don't think I was unclear on the origins
of that cash so that's very different
than a hand-to-hand drug sale but you
can hardly claim that you know I'm not
complicit in someone else's addiction
you know I think you know you have to be
willing to carry that also to too many
other harmful products but I think that
logic applies okay so you were you would
not argue for the legalization of all
drugs that's not one of the reforms you
come away advocating having seen how
long some sentences are for some people
involved it rather a low-level as you
note as you observe so many of your
fellow inmates were not sort of capable
enough to be very high in an
organization know also by I mean not
that women aren't capable of being high
in an organization but the reality of
woman's ability to sort of rise to the
head of underground economies is
debatable I don't know
as far as drug legalization this is what
I think I think that marijuana should be
legalized and I think that if we took
that step we would learn a lot about
the process and a lot a lot about what
works and what doesn't work and I think
that would be important to know before
we thought about next steps I agree with
you completely
let's talk about your book for a sec it
has two big spans of time before you
actually get incarcerated the first is
the span between your involvement in the
drug trade which was right after college
it you were several years past it living
downtown in New York with your boyfriend
now husband and I I imagine you had not
thought or worried about it you know in
a long time when when something happened
I worried about it less as every year
passed yeah it receded it didn't
disappear from my mind or my memory but
it receded and became more and more of
this sort of abstract crazy reckless
dangerous but but in my past thing but
you know karma you know what they say
about karma it comes comes back to haunt
you and so you know that knock on the
door came you know in a very warm spring
day down in down in the West Village and
and I definitely felt right from the
moment that I was informed that I'd been
indicted that the consequences would
definitely not be light yeah though when
I found myself standing in prison next
to women who were serving 7 and 10 years
and more and I had to scratch my head
and say it's it's hard for me to believe
that their offense was that much that
much worse than mine
I literally on the first day I arrived
in prison I was like I had nothing to
complain about huh felt that way really
powerfully yeah that's so interesting if
that knock on the door had not come fast
forward how many years now 15 maybe not
that many is it do you suppose you would
have
revealed this to your mate would this
have come out to my mate yes uh-huh
yes but this is definitely a
misadventure I had put in a lockbox yeah
yeah it's not something to brag about no
but it's nice that it can be something
it didn't weigh on you it's in fact
after you then went through the the meat
grinder of prosecution the the next
surprise for me in the book was you are
not immediately incarcerated yes and I
thought that waiting to be incarcerated
sounded a lot worse than waiting for the
knock on the door was that oh yes
definitely right so tell why you are not
incarcerated right away
I was not incarcerated right away I was
I'd been I was informed of my indictment
I was arraigned and I quickly pled
guilty all in the space of just a few
months in 1998 and almost immediately
after I entered my guilty plea I had a
plea agreement my lawyer called me from
Chicago and said you're not gonna
believe this I've got something kind of
crazy to tell you there were 13 other
people on my indictment my memory serves
me right I'm at the bottom of that list
and at the top of the list is a drug
kingpin who's a West African national
you know he's West African and lives in
West Africa and he had been taken into
custody in the UK on this warrant and
indicted as co-conspirator conspirators
exactly and this is not a person I've
ever met
he'd been taken into custody which was
shocking in and of itself and he was
being held and that triggered this
lengthy delay as they tried to extradite
him which they failed to do he was
released and so that was an almost
six-year delay and that kept you out of
prison why I think I mean I I can't
answer that with complete clarity but I
think in general the prosecutor wanted
gentle witnesses to appear in street
clothes rather than in orange jumpsuits
ironically when I did when I was in fact
called to appear in a trial I was
wearing an orange jumpsuit yeah that's
so interesting huh
okay so finally when when the US
government failed to extradite that
individual and he was released they
began to proceed with sentencing of me
and of other co-defendants right right
okay so I you had not written a book
before no were you an English major no I
was a theater major theater major so you
have a great store of detail from your
experience at Danbury wonderful
descriptions of the people you're with
and a facility for remembering things
people said which which I envied one of
my favorites was when you're being
processed as a new inmate you're in some
sort of orientation and there's a sort
of officious person talking down at all
of you inmates and one of your woman
they see these seated next to you says
Jesus F Christ who peed in her Cheerios
did you not write that down no I didn't
write that down at the time ya know but
those are vivid memories some I mean
they're all vivid memories but I can I
can see the I can see that room in my
mind just as we're talking about a
television room with sort of naive
paintings on the wall literally on the
wall and I remember the person who who
said that very vividly she was a
violator and I remember this was an
early parole violator yes so she she had
been in federal prison before she had
violated her parole she was a drug
addict
and she was back in jail and I this was
only a few days that I'd been in prison
and I was so stunned by the idea that
anyone would ever return to France yeah
right that I I remember focusing on her
really closely also she was nice yeah
she was a nice person right and you know
that room we're sitting in that room and
we're all pretty down we're all fresh
into some of the folks in that room had
been actually in confinement for some
time but we were all new to this
facility and in general the mood was
fairly low but she was in a pretty good
mood so that's one of the reasons she
sort of sticks out in my in my mind
right and her sort of salty tone you
know to your question though you know I
am a first-time writer I took I am NOT a
daily diary I did keep some journals
while I was there I was really lucky
most of my friends kept the letters I
wrote to them those were an invaluable
source of insight because you can't be
assured of leaving prison with your
journal even if you keep one all right
definitely not and in fact you couldn't
you didn't leave with your personal
property I didn't leave with anything
but one little piece of paper which was
paperwork but when I did leave the
prison I was going I knew I was going on
the federal transport you know Conair
right I was close to the end of my
sentence so I knew that there was a good
chance I would never return to Danbury I
should probably knock wood right now so
I gave away all my things when I say my
things my sweatpants my sneakers the the
things I'd bought from the commissary I
gave away
you know the good uniforms I'd accrued
my good blanket you know these are goods
prison property no I kept my crocheting
slippers and I got packed out and when
you get packed out that means that you
get packed out with the assistance of
enough of an officer and basically all
the personal belongings it was this
massive mound of paper and those
crocheted slippers and a couple of books
and my journal were put into a box and
put into storage in Danbury where I they
sat until I came home and then they were
shipped to me at home that box of
treasures frankly yeah
so and then back to the letters you know
a lot of my friends kept my letters to
them and photocopied them and sent them
to me what I began to write the book
okay but things like dialogue in the
book those are drawn from memory oh you
know I can't pretend otherwise sure
those memories are vivid but you know
drawn from memory absolutely not drawn
from a tape recorder right other than
the one in my head well I also I I just
know that when a person is in an
environment that is foreign and
upsetting in many ways memories tend to
be vivid very sharp yeah there's stuff
you just probably will never forget I'm
sure that there are many rooms that you
will never ever forget from inside sing
sing I was thinking about it this
afternoon yeah yeah which which rooms
are most vivid for you oh the horrible
gigantic monumental rooms of the cell
blocks
you know the architecture you don't run
into any other place but a prison with
the sounds and the smells of a place
like that absolutely yeah the sounds
alone are just that's one of my most
vivid memories yes sound and
interestingly you know the sounds in Dan
very very different than the sounds in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma City ironically a
very quiet place so the women's are all
different they're all different and then
Chicago the federal jail there that I
spent some hellish weeks in cacophonous
like just a noise that you think will
make you lose your mind right so the
soundscape is unlike anything else but I
was also struck when you got a new cube
neighbor a transsexual who asked you
vanessa was not given all of her
medication to stay as female as she had
been and and on a hot day you commented
on Vanessa had introduced a different
sort of smell scent yes a scent of a man
she'd be really angry if she was here
with us to hear that but it's true the
other fascinating thing about Vanessa is
that the the fact that they would not
provide her medications to her you know
changed her voice back a bit and
so she was able to surface drop her
voice and in a way and she loved to
actually scare that way because you'd
think she was an officer so she could
have a high voice but also a bellowing
voice exactly she was a wonderful person
yeah you know I couldn't she's speaking
of vivid memories yeah she provides many
yeah I supervised several male/female
transsexuals at sing-sing and I was
always grateful for this feminine
presence I mean they're not there
there's something in-between
and yet it's it sort of it's a relief to
have somebody there to interrupt the
monotony of single-sex living mm-hmm
absolutely yeah definitely so I think we
need to take a break right now okay all
right great afterwards and other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Piper Kerman and Ted
Conover in a moment if you're one of the
millions who enjoy our 16th president
you'll find a contemporary perspective
in c-span's book Abraham Lincoln now in
paperback at your favorite bookseller
learn more at c-span org slash Lincoln
book afterwards with Piper Kerman and
Ted Conover continues Piper
one difference between where I worked in
a state maximum-security prison for men
and the federal women's prison camp
where you did time was where you were it
appeared there were maxi pads everywhere
then they were they were useful in more
ways than one they are so useful can you
describe some of that maxi pads are one
of the few things the prison provides
you know there's an there are many ideas
about prison giveaways or freebies for
prisoners the only things that the
prison provided to us other than
uniforms sheets towels every week every
month there was the issuing of laundry
soap and in the bathrooms they provided
the very fundamental toiletries maxi
pads tampons toilet paper but anything
else you know anything else shampoo so
you know body soap for your body you
know toothpaste toothbrushes you're on
your own
but maxi pads and also and also tampons
were multi purposed they were
particularly useful as cleaning agents
rags rags and asses so you you know
prison living is in a lot of senses
modeled on perhaps military living
certainly it's dorm style living
barracks style living and one of the
mandates is keeping your your personal
area clean which is completely important
and cleaning was an incredibly important
ritual we had inspections failure or
success and the inspections contributed
to how early you got to eat or how late
you got to eat and therefore whether you
got the best food or not Sunday nights
particularly were highly ritualized
cleaning opportunities and generally you
were expected to clean with your
immediate your bunkmate or if you lived
in a room with multiple prisoners your
your roommates and so those maxi pads
would scrub the ceiling over my bunk
they would
scrub the floors we would use them too
as skids under lockers so that those
things were more easy to move so you
could clean you know people use them in
in many interesting ways primarily as
cleaning agent I was amazed and
delighted by that it seems thing there
is never-ending supply of toothbrushes
and toothpaste but we never once saw a
useful thing like that yes like a maxi
pad when you were describing just that
the hospital corners you know your own
cube mates said no no don't you make the
bed we'll show you how because there are
penalties for doing it wrong not only
that when you're getting ready to climb
into bed they say no no no don't get in
the bed so get this at the training
academy for correction officers in
Albany where I spent seven weeks it's
exactly the same you cannot you do not
climb under your top sheet because then
you'll have to remake that bag it's
exactly the same so it is surreal that
the office the officer culture and the
inmate cultures they're they're parallel
and they overlap in these ways that are
quite fascinating and and yet more
typically than what you described in
your book is this sort of darkly drawn
line between inmates and officers and
there's an officer I think in a truck
when you're on a work detail you're
outside the prison who wants to be
chatty with you wants to learn a little
bit about you what you're in for how a
nice girl like you ended up in a place
like this and you're not interested in
in having that conversation and I could
have been that guard because I was
always interested in learning about the
inmates in fact it was kind of a problem
I think connected to my education I
wanted in my mission which was to write
about this eventually I wanted to know
everything about them and a few inmates
would talk to me more would not so
what's at stake for an inmate
sharing that information why wouldn't
you try to bridge that gap there's a
couple things that are at stake for an
inmate in terms of how close they might
become to a guard I think what's true
for any inmate is that if you're
perceived as being cozy with staff then
there's a pretty good reason risk that
you might be a snitch and so that's
taken pretty seriously yeah on the other
hand it's completely accepted that there
are snitches and that there will always
be snitches so that's one risk so you
want to your reputation clean your
graduation is not fraternizing with
staff absolutely and that is a choice
you know I think some some inmates are
like to hell with it I'm gonna
fraternize with staff if I want to and I
don't care if you think I'm a snatcher
right but for myself you know that one
year I mean there were many times that I
was like thank God this is only a year I
sort of said you know I'm going to be
you know a worker among workers I'm
gonna be an inmate among inmates that's
you know that's the place of safety for
me that's the place of comfort for me
from a intellectual perspective you know
cozying up to your jailer is a very
stomach-turning proposition but on an on
another level and a pract on an
emotional level the risk of closeness
with someone who has a completely
different status than you you know
guards from my purse point of view have
complete power over inmates well in
particularly when it's a male yard and a
female inmate yes that's a different
situation so I was describing I imagine
I would feel no female guard ever
actually attempted to become friendly
with me I imagine even in that case I
would be very I would have been
uncomfortable with that because of that
power dynamic but then of course when
you lay in the sexual dynamic that that
adds an entirely new risk level of risk
as well for for the
made for the prisoner yeah and and
that's all really scary stuff and
ultimately you know the benefit of that
intimacy just the intimacy of two people
sort of treating the each other as human
beings and talking about themselves in a
way that's not guarded was frightening
right you described the annual
gynecological exam to which you were
entitled yes which many of your fellow
inmates said forget it it's it's this
man I don't I don't want to go through
that I'm gonna I'm not going in there
you said it's important I'm gonna do it
it was not a positive experience and you
wondered why they couldn't have supplied
a female gynecologist to look at all
these women a very reasonable question
well when I got to sing sing and when I
went through the Corrections Academy I
wondered both why there are women
working as officers in a male
institution and why there are males
working as officers in a female
institution and I believe it has to do
with equal employment opportunity but
did you ever wish all the staff was
female would that have made it better in
any way but it would have made it a
completely different place it would have
made it a dramatically different
experience I don't know whether it would
have made it better or worse it would
certainly make it less dangerous from
the perspective of sexual abuse which is
a huge problem in prisons male and
female prisons nationwide and every year
there are shocking stories that come out
shocking shocking and yet consistent
stories crazy things have happened in in
terms of women's facilities at the
federal institution in Tallahassee there
was an incident where a guard who had
been caught sexually abusing prisoners
started shooting other guards because he
knew he was going down you know recently
and I think it's Tennessee they moved
400 female prisoners because they found
that the institution where they'd been
held was just so that sexual abuse was
so rampant that they decided to simply
transport them out of there so it's not
something
you know safety the safety of prisoners
ironically is a really serious thing I I
think there would be benefits certainly
to parity in terms of male and female
officers I think that would make for a
very very very different environment and
I think that would be true in both - in
both men's facilities and women's
facilities the the guards in danbury and
in every unit that I was in were
overwhelmingly male and I think one of
the really the things that bothered me
certainly was that again that dynamic of
people who have near complete power over
one cohort of people who have near
complete power over another cohort of
people arranged along those gender lines
had this incredible effect on you know
on anyone mentally but also a lot of
women who are in prison have not have
not necessarily had all of the agency
that a middle-class woman might have in
terms of gender politics and in terms of
equality and so I think there's a
terrible reinforcement of that dynamic
that gender dynamic that takes place in
women's prisons because of that lopsided
population of the the male guard cohort
when you were preparing to write your
book were there models of narrative that
you used were their favorite books you
modeled yours on other books about women
in prison or other books of any kind
that that we're useful to you I loved
your book
yes it is I read your book with great
interest and at times total anger but
it's a great example of a personal
narrative it's different obviously
because you're you went into it with
journalistic intent that's completely so
there are so many personal narratives
that I've loved you know what I found as
I started out to write it was that
almost all of the
small narrative by women who either are
in prison or have been in prison is in
short form you know there's very little
it's so you know in anthology form and
there have been many anthologies of
women's writing from prison published
and a couple of great ones that were
edited by Wally Lamb who does a women's
writing program at the York Correctional
Facility here in New York so those were
fascinating those those document women
who come from you know very different
parts of the spectrum of experience from
mine so they're great I'm not an
experienced writer I sort of sat down to
just do it I've read a lot of wonderful
first-person narratives I'm trying to
think of the ones that might have been
most inspiring but I can't say I brought
a huge amount of art to it or a whole a
great deal of modeling as much as just
trying to document it was interesting I
went through the process of trying to
catalogue the experience first and I
think my first draft was probably very
excruciating to read I wrote it in a
month-by-month rubric like literally
every month that I spent in prison was
its own chapter diary a bit yes and I
think house that was detailed and
accurate but I think at one point my
editor made a note to me I think you're
trying to capture the incredible tedium
here any truly realistic prison book
would be really boring right because
there's so much that happens that is
dull dull dull yeah and yet we can't
fill the pages I mean when I think of
other personal narratives they're not
necessarily about prison though I do I
love yours because it's journalistic but
personal I mean books like oh the glory
of it all you know have a fascinating
effort to capture really painful
experiences with humor right and that
was incredibly important to me when I
set out because I felt what I felt when
I set out was that I wanted to write a
book that would be accessible to lots of
people I didn't see any
a reason to write it only for folks who
already knew about the person system
because frankly you know nothing I
reveal would be new to them so it was
important to write a book that was
really accessible and humor is part of
that though the other thing about humor
in the book and there is humor in the
book is that it's a fundamental part of
being a prisoner is is drawing on humor
in order it's a big survival tool yes so
that's in my mind a very accurate
representation of the experience right
know and dark humor I mean there can be
wonderful fantastic humor in prison it's
like where you need it the most
it is our experiences we're different
because I could come home every night
and yet I too was sort of counting the
days until I could say I've done enough
time here no it's time to go and yet on
the last day when I left for the very
last time I was seized with this strange
regret like I was leaving
thank God I was leaving this place but
it was I wasn't just leaving a place I
was leaving a number of people who knew
and depended on me for certain things
and I can't guess at what it must be
like from the other side to leave prison
but I wondered if you could just tell us
and you didn't leave Danbury for freedom
you left for another prison while you
were processed out and testifying but
what what did you miss when you left
there what were there any regrets about
what you were leaving oh I missed people
desperately especially in the in the
dramatically different discomforts of
Oklahoma City and of Chicago but you
know so I missed some of the the
comforts of ritual that I had created
for myself in Danbury or that had been
created for me when I was in Oklahoma
City for example I missed the ability to
go to work
you know the tedium of a facility where
you truly cannot do anything is shocking
but those
bonds that you form which you know
objectively makes sense you're going
through a dramatic and intense relay
experience with other people yeah you're
going to rely on each other to survive
you're gonna you're gonna form intense
bonds I miss them so much
and as I I miss many of them still
but in those months when I was still
incarcerated but no longer in Danbury it
was shocking to me when I got to
Oklahoma City that I felt homesick for
Danbury and not for the outside world it
was sort of a disgusting I'm a you know
I was [ __ ] I was disgusted with myself
but that was the truth yeah and then
when I got to Chicago I was like I'm
homesick from the city but that's what
my you know when I was about to leave to
go on that segment of the journey my
boss in in the construction shop a heavy
smoker and a quiet man made a reference
to diesel therapy yeah and I had no idea
what are you talking about and that's
what I what I understood in the course
of that final leg of my journey was what
he meant by diesel therapy the idea that
tough circumstances make you appreciate
what you have what you have had or what
you lost
uh-huh so this is gonna seem good to you
mm-hmm
where you're going now yeah yes there's
a a full circle feeling that comes when
you've left Danbury the reader knows
that you were likely fingered by the
woman you call Nora who you'd been
involved with and who you got involved
in carrying money as a consequence with
and and yet you don't you haven't been
in touch with her I think you may have
heard she's incarcerated but you you
don't know
details but once you are summoned to
testify at a trial regarding another
member of your conspiracy you realize
there's a pretty good chance you're
going to see her again and then sure
enough and let me I don't want to tell
the story but let me just say one of my
favorite scenes in the book
is when I guess you're in Oklahoma City
with Jay is mm-hmm
and you've spotted Nora and tell tell
what Jay says to you Jay think she knows
what you want to do right so I had
fantasized many times in my mind a
moment when our past my cross you know
this this woman who in a lot of sense as
I still blamed for involving me in this
and generally I set those you know in
you know not in prison but you know in a
bar where I'd be able to grab a
poolhouse second I'm not a violent
person
but in that context of prison the idea
of someone who has ratted you out is a
really powerful idea and I felt at that
moment like I had this opportunity to
exact revenge which how might you have
done that if you had no impulse control
well if you had no impulse control you'd
go to town on her you know you I did I
fortunately didn't have a law you're
sitting in a cafeteria this is a very
Spartan unit in Oklahoma City it kind of
reminded me of a really clean train
station yeah clean quiet train station
but you know a very institutional and
maximum-security facility so really
there was anything's bolted to the walls
you know a tiny little rolling cart of
the lobby of the library and I caught
sight of her across the room and I knew
that she hadn't seen me yet so I would
have had the element of surprise if I
had no impulse control and was in fact
you know not in any way prone to
violence like the sort of conceit that
you would have expected in that setting
was that I'd have attacked her well in
Jay said if you got if there's something
you have to do I understand but try not
to didn't absolutely and Jay was a
friend of mine a woman I'd befriended at
work who was serving a ten year sentence
and was she was pretty early in the
sentence a very warm and solid person
who
- had my back in the past right and she
sort of let me know you know I'm not
gonna back you up if you do something
crazy yeah you know I understand if you
have if you feel like you have to do
something crazy but it's the wrong thing
to do
yeah she said you're about to go home
you got a guy who comes to see you every
week which you know was not something a
lot of people had she said you know sort
of you know suck it up yeah a little bit
and you did and I did yes and you know
again I'm not a person who has no
impulse control I'm not a person who's
ever used violence to get what I want I
tried to put a lot of distance between
myself and that person initially and I
really stood I really sat and stood but
by the time we arrived in Chicago to the
federal jail there I was ready to sort
of confront her not physically but but
personally conversationally and it was
an interesting moment there in Chicago
when I turned a very important emotional
corner or personal corner and sort of
realized that my fantasies about revenge
were really fruitless and blamed that I
associated with her in terms of my
current situation was not well placed
that that blame resided with me and that
the ability to forgive her made me a
bigger person and a better person yeah
and that was an incredible I mean I do
remember that moment of realization that
is one of those Thunderbolt moments in
one's life and it's I'm grateful I'm
very grateful that that happened in
three or four pages the value of
forbearance is it abundantly Illustrated
and in that she then claims that she was
not the one who first fingered you do
you have any resolution of that and I
have no resolution and the really thing
that I'm also very grateful is that I
just don't really much care
it's great I mean the realization that
it really doesn't matter yeah at all so
let's talk about that idea though that
in forgiving you grow I think in our
culture there's an idea that a diversity
of experiences makes a gross character
that as you yourself write early on what
doesn't kill you makes you strong it's
prison one of those things oh I mean
it's easy for me who served only a year
in prison to say that I'm grateful for
some of the things that I learned there
the the danger and the tragedy I think
of prison as a social tool yeah and of a
long sentences especially is that a lot
of the insights that I feel I gained I
gained through hard personal work which
is the choice of the person from a
systemic point of view right I think
that the folks expect oh we'll send
someone to prison then they'll learn a
lesson I think the only thing that
you're guaranteed that the prison system
is guaranteed to teach you is how to be
a prisoner mm-hmm
and it's not a skill set that serves you
well on the outside world no analog and
you do you absolutely learn how to be a
prisoner it's very important to learn
how to be a prisoner if you want to
survive in prison yeah and when we send
someone to prison for long periods of
time
the life of the institution I'm sure
that this is something you might agree
with based on based on reading your own
book the life of the institution
completely overtakes your your mind and
your world and you did get to go home
every day but you write about that in
your own book the degree to which the
life of that institution in your place
in it dominates so when you when you
live inside a prison as a prisoner for
10 years the idea that you will walk on
the street and be able to reintegrate
into society is incredibly naive yeah
well the character in orange is the new
black who
illustrated that for me most vividly was
your bunkmate pop an older woman her
whole name was Popovich was that it more
the she's the cook in the kitchen at
Danbury she's been in more than 10 years
yep she served over 10 years she was my
buddy not much she was not my bunkie oh
right I was my friend she was one of my
dearest friends and she has a strong
social network in in that facility and
she's released right around the time you
are and more than anyone else that it
reminded me of that image I think it's
from a John Irving novel of a there's a
gas station he writes about that had a
pet tiger and a big cage there was an
old Esso station or something and one
day they left the the get the door open
by a mistake the tiger wasn't going
anywhere he that the tiger was afraid to
leave the cage and the tiger probably
could not survive outside the cage and I
I thought about that with pop you know
she's not young she's a creature of
habit she works really hard but even on
days when she has a vacation she goes to
work because that's what she knows and a
person like that suddenly thrust into
the big world which she left before
internet before cellphones before
keyless entry to cars I'm sure I mean
what's what are we doing to people yeah
absolutely the good news about pop about
a person like pop is that she did have
ties to the outside world she had strong
ties to the outside world in in terms of
her family yeah so there was a clear
pathway home for her and a warrant and a
ferocious work ethic that husband was in
prison though her husband wasn't pretty
but you know she was yes definitely and
fully there yeah that's the other thing
that I'm I'm sure is really true in all
prisons
is that mental acuity or mental illness
makes a massive difference in how folks
serve their sentences on how successful
they are at returning home so pop didn't
have any of those challenges there's
another person that I talked about mrs.
Jones in the book who served longer
sentence I believe then pop and mrs.
Jones is a person who I fear for far
more I don't I don't know where mrs.
Jones is she's definitely gone home
since then the Caribbean no no no she
was a steely haired Irish Irish American
woman and she was she ran the puppy
program okay so there was one of the few
programs rehabilitative programs was a
program for training service dogs and
she had been involved in that program
since it started but she was not she
certainly had a work ethic you know just
as just as prodigious as pops but she
had far more tenuous ties to the outside
world she was even more committed to the
life of the institution as it were and
you know had some serious I think mental
health challenges right and so a person
like mrs. Jones is someone who I really
feared for yes literally like on a
visceral level was scared for her to go
home and that's a terrible horrible
thing yes it is I think there but for
the grace of God absolutely yeah
after leaving sing-sing met a parole
officer who'd meet prisoners who just
came into the city once released from
sing singing say some of these were big
you know pumped up guys they he he
talked about one guy in particular with
a slight retardation he said you could
almost see his heart pounding inside his
chest like a little bird and he said
what you see on the outside is not at
all what what's going on inside lots of
times that was probably the most I mean
other than the visiting watching folks
with their kids in the visiting room
which could break your heart
watching prisoners who were scared to go
home yeah not nervous everyone's nervous
to go home but you can tell the
difference between people who are simply
nervous about all of the reentry
factors that make anyone nervous myself
included and people who are truly
fearful that was heartbreaking us you
know there were many women who were
going home home to homeless shelters you
know to incredibly uncertain futures to
environments of violence to really scary
stuff and that it gave me a terrible
feeling my stomach that prison might be
a safer place for some folks that's a
great thought but but it's a good book
and thank you